the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok interactive teaching here is a famous
graph produced by Benjamin bloom and his
students so here on this axis is student
achievement so after a course is over
students are tested on the material and
here's their score and this is the
percentage who attained each score so
here they compared to well actually
three methods of teaching but I'll just
compare two so one method is standard
one group instruction say one to thirty
more today maybe one to 90
and here's the histogram the
distribution of students scores you
nicely spread out now by itself it
doesn't say much but what's really
interesting is the distribution
basically after the same amount of
teaching but done in the tutorial form
with one to one or maybe one to two and
to put some quantitative figures on this
from blooms results the average so this
is one-to-one tutoring one to thirty
the average tutorial student is two
Sigma's better than the group students
in other words the average tutorial
student is at the 98th percentile of the
ordinary teaching group so the question
is the natural question is how can we
make group instruction as effective as
tutorial instruction as Benjamin bloom
says he says finding such methods would
be an educational contribution of the
greatest magnitude because for example
it would change our notions about human
potential we'd actually realize oh
actually there's not that much innate in
what people can do most of it is how
well they've learnt how well they've
been taught so the great question and
this the title of blooms paper is the
search for methods of group instruction
has effective as one-to-one tutoring to
that end let's think about the following
question which is what makes tutoring so
effective so I'm going to ask you that
to consider that question in scoops of 2
or 3 and 3 whatever is sort of
convenient in your region of the room so
what makes tutoring so effective after
you discuss will take reasons put them
on the board and
I'll show you methods of group
instruction that may not quite get us
all the way to tutoring but that answer
many of the good characteristics of
tutoring and bring them into group
instruction okay so please find one or
two neighbors introduce yourselves you
never know you might find a teaching
colleague yeah and think about what
makes tutoring so effective okay so take
30 seconds and collect your thoughts
together
okay who would like to suggest something
that your group thought of you don't
necessarily have to believe it just
something you discussed and think we
should share yes can you tell me your
name
Elena okay you can nip misconceptions in
the bud
okay so whereas in for example a group
instruction you may not even know the
students have a misconception until the
final exam then what do you do okay
let's see yeah could you tell me your
name oh could you tell me your name
right okay so the contrast in this is
the what's what it's a teaching
situation look like in a typical lecture
someone may just talk at you for 50
minutes whereas it's hard to imagine a
one-on-one tutorial situation where you
walk in for your tutorial and they just
talk at you for 15 minutes that would
seem so odd and so counter to all
conventions of human discussion I every
week it would take a really really
disciplined and well-trained person to
sit still for 50 minutes for that kind
of treatment right
so not necessarily a good kind of
training either
okay so cannot so you cannot Yammer at
the audience for 50 minutes straight
yes good tell me your name could you
tell me your name Whitney
student experiences
okay cuz they they're talking in a small
group so they can get validation in a
safe setting is that okay so it's safe
it's a a safe setting for raising ideas
maybe that you're not sure about okay
there was many more yeah tell me your
name Martin okay so you can tailor the
teaching according to what you find out
so sort of like the the new electronic
SATs right according to what you don't
know or do know in each question they
give you questions based on your
previous answers at the right level of
difficulty so you can tailor okay so
let's see yeah can you tell me your name
yeah
okay you can tailor the teaching style
to the student if for example the
student is you know for example suppose
you're teaching math to somebody who's
an architect well you can use lots of
examples that are particular to
something they're totally fascinated by
this you can tailor teaching method okay
let me get something for me somewhere
back there if I case I've been
collecting people way in the back okay
you guys had your chance
I'll be back yeah didn't come your name
okay great okay so it's sort of the
level of engagement is much higher in a
tutorial so that's the complement of
this one so the student engagement is
much higher
you know just as it's hard for a teacher
in a tutorial setting to just talk for
50 minutes straight it's also hard for a
student in a tutorial session to surf
the web for 50 minutes straight or you
know use their Blackberry or read the
newspaper or whatever it may be that the
standard methods of lecture distraction
are yes know what yeah so what they did
was so this I don't think these were
university students I think these were
high school and in grade school students
yeah but what they did was they took the
same number of teaching hours and they
either taught them in lecture or they
taught them in tutorials one-on-one or I
think sometimes one on two yeah yeah I
mean I don't know if they actually went
to the big class but I'm sure they went
to the tutorial class so that's one I
and that's part of one of the difference
since that's number six yes way in the
back okay and how do you find that out
okay so you can ask them questions
specific questions to figure out what
they don't know to diagnose what they're
confused about okay let's take one more
and then I'll show you some methods that
hopefully address what these
characteristics what these missing
characteristics of group instruction yes
okay right so the method of teaching out
it automatically adjusts to whatever
level the student is and so they're not
comparing to other people they're
actually just comparing to what they
don't know right then so it's let's
let's call it intrinsic comparison with
the knowledge rather than extrinsic with
other students okay so there's less you
know emotional churn as a result of that
let's call it that okay so we could
continue this list but this is an
excellent start and so now if we look
through that list there are several
themes that come out I mean it's hard in
a group and setting to figure out what
students don't know it's hard to ask
them questions it's hard to keep people
engaged it's easy to just talk at people
as a teacher so how what can we do in
group teaching to capture as many
characteristics of this as we can
well I'll show you methods that are I
divided into four time scales ranging
from short to long but before I do that
let me ask if there are any questions on
anything so far okay you are first
yeah that was a test score so what they
did is they gave them actually they gave
him this a test basically like if it was
algebra they gave him an algebra test
and they tested him at the end and at
the beginning too just to see where they
were to start with well if the tutoring
was whatever they needed to do well on
the test and the lecturing was hopefully
designed that way too but it had all the
flaws of you know you want to teach too
so students will do well on your final
exam but what do you do when you have 30
diverse students in there you had a
question - we have some idea because
good question the question is which of
these is most important and which is
less important actually they're all
getting at something similar but there's
a middle group in there actually that
they studied which was mastery learning
so mastery learning I it's it's like a
program of instruction so the idea is
that teller plan is another word for it
so mastery learning is midway between
tutoring and group instruction there was
one Sigma better so 84th percentile so
mastery learning you don't go on to the
new topics until you pass the mastery
exam on the previous topic so you're
always building on a solid foundation
and so you work until you can pass the
exam and then you continue on and just
by adding that to group instruction you
get one Sigma better so know right away
diagnosing misconceptions you can see
it's quite important but there's still
another one Sigma to get and so that's I
think what all the rest of these items
are about and when we do know a lot of
stuff about how people learn I mean one
of it is questions questions are
essential so I'm going to talk about
that but let me just ask again any
questions
okay good this time it works okay so now
what did I do
so this this is actually the first
method so how long did I wait after I
said any questions half a second one
minute no five seconds so the first time
I didn't wait five seconds because
actually a question came up a little
before five seconds but this time the
second time I waited five seconds now
why is that so that is the first method
when you ask a question mmm for example
any questions or what do you think about
this wait five seconds and I'll explain
why in a second but these methods
shortest to longest the reason I divide
them by shortest to longest is a they're
also they're the easiest the shortest
ones are the easiest to incorporate into
your teaching so anytime you teach you
ask a question wait five seconds so the
five second times okay so why do I wait
five seconds and why not two seconds
well the the reason is think about your
audience
suppose you're talking away at them and
all of a sudden you ask a question now
they're what are they hearing so
everyone's seen Charlie Brown so what is
Charlie Brown here when he goes to
school wah wah wah wah wah wah wah wah
wah wah wah wah and all of a sudden that
changes and there's a question it takes
about a second to realize that the wah
wah wah has stopped and you're being
asked a question okay so one seconds
gone okay let's call it that tooth um
one second now it takes about another
second to even figure out what the
question is you know here now you say oh
yeah there's a question being asked what
did they say okay maybe now let's say
it's a one and a half second so now
we're at like somewhere between two and
three seconds now it takes maybe a one
or two more seconds to figure out what
you're going to say about that do I have
any thoughts about it do I actually have
any questions do I have a thought about
the thing they're asking me do I know
what the bandgap is in silicon whatever
the question may be so now you're
somewhere between four maybe near five
seconds and then it maybe takes another
second to get the courage up to raise
your hand and be ready with a sentence
so now we're at at least five seconds so
if you don't wait those five seconds
what you'll get is you'll be getting a
few questions but you'll get questions
from people who have already thought
about the material in other words the
people who are already at the 98th
percentile but if you want to bring
everybody in and get everybody thinking
about it you really need to wait so you
don't get questions just from the usual
suspects so wait five seconds now the
mechanism is quite important if you just
say okay I'm going to wait five seconds
you'll go any questions
Oh done five seconds is up right because
and you'll think five seconds is up in
about one second and then why is that
well you're up in front of a whole bunch
of people and the adrenaline will be
flowing an adrenaline speeds up your
time sense but all those stories about
people who like mothers who saw their
kid about to get hit by the car and they
race out and grab the kid and the car
keeps going you know maybe it screeches
to stop but doesn't man they've managed
to rescue their kid well they could act
much faster because adrenaline makes a
time sense much sharper so your idea of
five seconds will be more like something
like one second there's another reason
which is there's this mistaken idea that
if you're not talking you're not
teaching so you're being paid to teach
and oh my god you're not saying anything
that means you must not know something
so you feel insecure and that increases
the adrenaline and only speeds up the
time problem or so to get wait five
seconds you actually have to count it
one one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand four one thousand five one
thousand and I actually sometimes just
do it behind my back with my hand one
one thousand two one thousand three one
thousand four one thousand five one
thousand and it's not like you have to
be watching the audience for the whole
five seconds right it's actually better
to wait the whole five seconds and
choose one of the hands that have gone
up rather than the first hand that goes
up at two seconds you say oh thank god
somebody asked the question okay now my
waiting is over
well again you'll be back in the usual
suspect soup so first timescale for
bringing in questions but in other words
spreading the engagement through the
class because questions when people are
asking questions they're by definition
engaged they're struggling with the
material they're trying to make it their
own wait five seconds okay the next
method so the next method is short time
scale one minute and that is to use a
feedback sheet at the end of every
teaching session so you actually have an
example of a feedback sheet that will
ask you to fill out at the end of this
session which we handed out at the
beginning and the blank versions of that
sheet will also be on the tll website so
you can actually download it print it
and use it in your own teaching as well
as my notes on how to use it but the
main point is that at the end of the
class you give the students one or two
minutes to fill out a feedback sheet and
what I've converged on is the following
three questions on my feedback sheet
which is what was most confusing you
know basically what question you have
that still wasn't answered second
question is what was the most useful or
most useless example or demonstration or
teaching method that happened today and
the third question is any other comments
so now let me explain why I use those
three questions the first question the
sheets are all anonymous and it's a
chance for someone if they felt a little
bit shy asking questions in front of you
know people so here in the tutorial one
of the characteristics that was
mentioned was that you don't feel
nervous about asking a question because
there's no one there maybe there's just
one other person there whereas in a
class of 30 or 80 or 20 you may feel a
bit nervous well if you feel a bit
nervous you just put your question on
the feedback sheet and so then at the
beginning of the next session I answer
all the questions on the feedback
so it takes me more than one minute but
actually not that much longer because
you can flip through a hundred sheets in
about ten minutes you can you just
glanced through you'll see a bunch of
questions are repeated and you'll say oh
yeah I do really need to explain that
and at the beginning of the next session
just explain all the important points
that Emma and that has another benefit
which is that it links back to the
previous lecture of the previous
teaching session so now you've made a
thread between the previous session and
the current one and got everyone up to
speed into the space where you want them
to be so that's why I use the first
question the second question is what
worked or didn't work and I also have to
add and tell me whether it worked or
didn't work because I used to get
example saying that example and I didn't
know whether they loved it or hated it
so then I said please tell me the sign
of the effect as well and then I would
know I would start to build a model of
how students think and what works for
them so every time basically I learned
that I brought in a demonstration there
was Universal love on the second
question so I said oh okay that really
connects with students and I would make
sure to do more of that so it was
reinforcement for me and practice for me
of being a better teacher right and what
you'll find is that as you use the sheet
more and more you get better and better
at predicting how students think so for
example you're doing some discussion on
the board some examples some derivation
and the first time you do it maybe you
don't know it's not going to go well and
then you read the sheet and you see oh
my god that was a disaster
30 questions out of 80 all said I didn't
understand X so now you understand that
students didn't understand the way you
did it well now you've melt a better
model of how students think
so next time you're doing a derivation
what you'll find is at least what I
found is in the middle of the derivation
I'll realize oh this is not going well
I'm gonna get a lot of questions about
this on the sheet oops but it's too late
I'm in the middle of the soup I can't
undream the soup so I just finished the
soup and just wait for the questions all
right but then after you know maybe
another week of using the sheet you
actually have quite a good model to
students and now before you start the
derivation or when you're planning their
lecture you realize oh yeah that's not
going to go well let me do
this other way because I know that works
better so you'll find your model of the
students developing more and more
refinements and more and more accuracy
in other words you're becoming a more
expert teacher and then the third
question on the sheet is any other
comments the reason for that is it's
just a free-form space and I've actually
had students say oh you know actually
when you explain that thing you actually
explained it wrong I was like oh that's
good to know so then the beginning of
the because we did it properly in this
other class and here's the exact
reference that you might didn't know
about I was like oh great so that the
beginning of the next class I say hey
why don't you guys pointed out a mistake
I made and here is the corrected version
and people might not be willing to say
that personally because I say oh my god
I don't want to correct the professor
and make them feel stupid but you know
it's much easier to do it on an
anonymous sheet so I get really useful
information on that and sometimes you
can figure out who did it so you can
send him an email saying oh thanks that
was useful and it is hey so you may
think oh no you don't want to be
corrected but actually after you tell
the students the following enough so
it's again back to this in a group
students feel like oh my god I don't
want to make a mistake and so I give
them the following speech quite often
because if you don't make mistake but I
tell them look all right how much did
you know when you were born I'm not a
hell of a lot couldn't talk could hardly
walk well how did you learn stuff right
did you just all of a sudden start
walking and talking no you mangled your
grammar you put Edie at the end of every
participle even though some don't have
that right and eventually you sorted it
all out and you stood up straight and
you walked so basically how did you
learn by making mistakes so the only way
to learn is to make mistakes so if you
don't make any mistakes you will learn
you'll know as much at the start of your
class as at the end of the class so you
want to make mistakes so I tell them
that a bunch of times but if then I'm
really embarrassed about making mistakes
and I defeated the whole purpose of
telling the students that so I actually
thanked them whenever they point out
something that I didn't do right okay so
that's the second time scale now the
third time scale is not that much longer
it's about let's say four or five
minutes
and it's a question which I'll call a
conceptual multiple-choice question and
I'll give you an example okay so here is
the question that I'll use to illustrate
it here is a pyramid with a square base
and it's it's B by B the length of one
side of the base is B and the height the
perpendicular height of the pyramid is H
okay so what's the volume
okay so everyone understand the question
okay give it a try so it find your group
of one or two any questions
any confusions about the question don't
give me any answers just yet but any
confusions about the question okay so
find your groups of one or two one or
two other people and we'll discuss that
question in a couple minutes okay so
anyone want to say anything about this
section I haven't heard from yeah go
ahead could you just say your name Brian
okay so you like D but not the others
okay could you tell me for example why
you don't like a okay so you would like
that to be B squared right whereas it's
just a single B in a single age okay so
you don't like that because the
proportionality is wrong doesn't scale
correctly so let me put here bad scaling
what was another problem oh it has bogus
units
okay so there's bogus dimensions no
there they're pretty much
interchangeable I use units to mean like
meters or feet or something and
dimensions to be things like length but
they're pretty much interchangeable in
usage so scaling bad scaling bad
dimensions okay anyone have any comments
about B same problem in fact it's even
more horrendous right well it starts out
okay I mean at least as far as
dimensions are concerned but then what
does it do this has the wrong dimensions
that is a right
then you add them that is terrible okay
so the dimensions are just bogus ah okay
can anyone say anything about number C
choice C yeah okay so if you stop on
this pyramid and step on it till H goes
to zero what happens to the volume here
goes to infinity yeah it's terrible so
the extreme cases are just bogus okay so
it fails that test okay now we're back
to D so who likes deep okay so we a few
people like to who de okay go ahead oh
you don't like D okay why not okay so so
this is the volume of a box in other
words if I had vertical sides so let me
draw vertical sides here
right so whereas the pyramid is actually
got to be less now it's kind of
mysterious what this factor here should
be yeah but it's definitely less than
one so this so this is comparison with
box so it has good properties and it's a
good answer it's just not correct but
that's okay because there's a lot of it
it's important to realize what's good
about it and what's not good about it so
it satisfies the extreme cases it
satisfies the dimensions it scales
correctly like you pointed out you want
B squared because it's the area down
there so it's good it's not all good
let's call it good mostly but as they
say you know a Miss is as good as a mile
except in horseshoes and atom bombs all
right so so good mostly but box
comparison
okay so now what so let me cross this
guy out and that guy yeah so what do you
conclude from that they're all wrong so
here's another multiple choice question
okay so who votes for a one of these is
definitely correct no votes for a who
votes for B oh I'm hurt I'm hurt well B
is in fact correct
so every once in a while I throw the
students a curveball and make all the
choices wrong now why would I do that
such an evil dastardly thing
well it's good every once in a while to
do that in fact I found that out
experimentally because the first time I
used this question with the students I
was already using the feedback sheets
and on the feedback sheets I got back
tons of love on the comment sheets they
said they say student said oh we love
that having all the answers right wrong
but don't do it too often but do it
every once in a while maybe once a month
or so all right and that way they never
know when it's coming so they always
have to check all the answers they can't
just do everything by elimination so it
is a very useful thing to do there are
other reasons for it too and if you're
curious ask me the questions I'll
explain more reasons to do it but that's
already a sufficient reason all right
okay so that's method 3 and you see you
get a bit of discussion you get multiple
choices and what does that allow you to
do right away well what was one of the
problems is you can find out what
misconceptions students have early so
point one up there in a tutorial you can
ask students questions well why not ask
some questions in a big lecture too so
that's what we just did so you can find
out if 90% of the students get it like
that you know you don't have to say much
more about the topic but if the answers
are distributed at the monkey line you
know 25 percent for all the ants
then you know there's going to be
trouble and it's worth actually
expanding on this point and the theme
that that question gets across right
then in lecture so you can make it much
more tailored to the group of students
you have and the students also what
happens in their small groups right so
remember we mentioned that in a tutorial
that it's a safe setting for raising
questions whereas a big group might not
be well what have we done
by letting everyone work in groups of
two or three we've created a whole bunch
of safe settings for questions and so
the students are free to discuss in
their groups of two or three and if they
can't resolve it there well then they
feel pretty confident that it's
worthwhile sharing it with the whole
class maybe the whole class can actually
learn something from that as well
okay so then that has another benefit
which is that it gets around a the
gender imbalance so to illustrate this
problem I was once in a bookstore in New
York and I was standing in the computer
section and this couple walked up the
stairs and the woman asked the man oh
there's some big fat book on Java and
she said what's Java and within a
millisecond not batting an eyelid he
said oh it's a fastest search engine on
the internet which is completely rubbish
but it's a programming language I so it
has absolutely nothing to do with the
search engine I'm sure no search engine
is ever even written in Java so it has
nothing to do with searching so it's
complete lie all right but he said it so
fast so there's a dichotomy there which
is generally speaking it's called
actually male answer syndrome and the
women I see all the way man laughing
yeah or I hear all the women laughing
well what you'll find is generally men
are very willing to talk about stuff
they know nothing about and speaking
crudely in extreme caricatures and
whereas women are reluctant to talk
about stuff they even know about so if
you just ask a question to a group just
flat out even with the five-second wait
you're more likely to get questions from
or responses from the guys than from the
girls so the way to render that I'm
going to try to mitigate that imbalance
to give people first a safe setting for
asking questions and then people
actually calibrate to the correct level
about well is this a reasonable idea is
it's not a reasonable idea cuz people
around me have good ideas about it as it
resolved now it's not well it's probably
safe to raise in a bigger setting so
you'll actually fix the gender balance
to a large extent and balance it out so
it has lots of benefits that you get
from tutorial teaching so now I'll show
you the last one
which we won't actually do for half an
hour but I just want to sketch out how
you could do a question for half an hour
by showing you the kind of question that
works in that time frame so this is
could be multiple choice doesn't have to
be but some kind of conceptual question
with lots of discussion and often it may
have a demonstration so let me show you
that particular question so I'm going to
use I have these guys too but I also
have the wood blocks which I like so
much so here are two wood blocks cut for
me by the machine shop of the Cambridge
physics department when I taught there
so they cut them out of the same piece
of pine and the only green direction
everything the only difference is this
is two centimetres thick and that's one
centimeter thick but they're both a foot
long and five centimetres wide so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to tap this
block and you'll hear a note every one
here the note great ok so now the
question is when I tap this block is a
note going to be higher the same
frequency or lower okay so now everyone
understand the question
okay so discuss with your neighbors I
will take a vote in about a couple of
minutes I won't give you the ten minutes
I would normally give people to discuss
and argue all right we'll take a couple
reasons and we'll do the experiment okay
time to vote
so just to sketch out how this could
actually turn into a 30 minute question
normally I give students about mmm a
couple minutes to think on their own and
then take a vote and then set everyone
to argue with each other I say in
particular find someone who has a
different answer than you and try to
convince them of your answer okay so
then you got a big argument going and so
then I let that go for about ten minutes
and then we take another vote and then
we discuss so let's just imagine we've
skipped forward to the end of the group
discussion and we're going to take the
second vote so who thinks let's see the
thick block will have a higher frequency
than the thin block about maybe 20
people who thinks they'll be equal 25
who thinks the thick block will have a
lower frequency about 50 okay so we have
a good spread of opinion there yeah so
now again in the scenario of the 30
minute question I would ask for reasons
and just like I did here and I would
just be the scribe I would just write
down people's reasons for a B or C for
greater equal or less than just make
sure I understand the reason and then
write it down I don't have to agree with
the reason just to make sure I
understand it and the person who says it
says yeah that's what I'm trying to say
write it on the board people then give
people the opportunity to say a reason
for any of the others or against any of
them or comment on any reason already on
the board okay and that can go for
another ten minutes or so
sometimes even longer and then I ask
people okay the test of science is
experiment should we do the experiment
should we do the experiment yeah okay
so just to remind you of the earlier
tone
so the eyes have it we okay so it turns
out to be roughly almost a factor of two
higher and frequency almost a full
octave it's not quite if they were
infinitely thin and this or twice
infinitely thin it would be exactly a
factor of two but because they have a
finite thickness it's not quite true but
that's how xylophones worked in fact
many people have reasoned their way to
the correct answer by thinking about
xylophones and many people have reasoned
their way to the incorrect answer by
thinking about guitar strings which
brings up a very interesting discussion
you can have alright so what did you
notice about here when I was about to
tap the second one could you hear a pin
drop right student engagement is much
higher because people are involved but
the act of voting commits people to a
public view and they want to know is
this right or is this not right and the
act of voting has another benefit which
is that you get a much better error
signal whereas suppose you didn't vote
and suppose you thought well it could be
higher because it's stiffer on the other
hand it's bigger wavelength so it's
lower and you sort of have both reason
in your head you're in this
superposition state and then the
experiment happens being being being in
it's higher and you say oh yeah I knew
that it was higher because it's the
thicker and stiffer all right so you
think actually you understood everything
but you didn't actually figure out well
which of these two reasons is right and
why whereas if you actually have to
publicly commit to one answer then you
get a clearly defined signal back about
whether that answer was right or not so
it's very important to make sure people
vote and it's the same time it's very
important to make sure people are not
punished for voting not so it doesn't
matter in my classes whether people get
the vote right or not I just want them
to vote and so then I have to give my
speech about it's better to be wrong
than right question
the professor asked a question wait 30
seconds people raised their hand and by
the time his nerd she's done there's
dirt of the class raising their hand and
those are probably what their hands up
first so how do you actually sorry could
you tell me what they're doing I didn't
they they asked a question do they let
the whole class discuss it yeah it's
really key to let the whole class
discuss so what I the normal structure
for a long question like this one I'll
do is I'll make sure everyone
understands the question and then I'll
let people think by themselves for a
minute or two and take a vote after that
a straw poll I call it so people don't
feel it's too
too weighty the reason for that is that
people have different learning styles
and some people want to think longer for
themselves and some people want to just
start talking right away so I want to
give something for everybody and then
after I take that vote that gives me an
idea of where the class is and it gives
a class an idea of where they are and
who has different views and then they
can start arguing with each other and so
now they've had a lot of time to
actually check what they all think so
people will have had arguments in their
group that they can't resolve so they're
very eager to actually share the
argument whereas if you just ask the
question without having giving people
time to struggle with it you're not
you're basically wasting the effect of
the question
so it so the so this is a hard question
but it's so rich it has so many things
so I don't expect most people to get the
question right in fact when I asked this
to faculty and physics departments when
I get physics teaching seminars most
people get it wrong all right so I won't
say all the places where that's been
true but it's been at many universities
around the world so I don't expect
people to get it right and I don't care
the point the reason for it is that it
introduces so many ideas about for
example spring models of solids we can
use musical instruments as analogies
that I think it's worth spending even a
whole class on it and in fact one time
somebody said well but a xylophone all
the things are the same thickness and
they're just longer how does that work
and I said oh I'm glad you asked that
and I pulled out my daughter xylophone
she has a baby xylophone from my
backpack and so we analyzed the
xylophone right there so it leads to so
many interesting things that I'm willing
to spend a whole class on it so that's
how I decide how much time to allocate
to something if if it's a really core
idea spend more time on it if it's
peripheral tend to spend less time on it
or do a really short question on it if
at all and then the difficulty I like to
get questions ideally I mean this one's
different just because it's so rich but
ideally where students are sort of at 60
percent correct thinking by themselves
maybe 65 even 70 because even though
they may be right that sounds like oh
they're mostly fine but they may not
know why they're right so then in the
discussion they can solidify their
reasons and maybe get up to 80 or 90
percent whereas if you've got a question
where they're 30 percent correct to
start with and there doesn't have other
redeeming qualities like the richness of
it you'll just propagate noise
throughout the system right and just
basically wrong ideals will just spread
all over and you spend all your time
correcting those so I gauge the
difficulty based on trying to hit that
mark okay so hopefully you've seen first
of all that tutorial teaching the main
points from today or is much more
effective than regular teaching as
normally practiced because of these
characteristics generally questioning
feedback instant feedback and corrective
feedback right away but through series
of methods you can bring many of the
benefits of tutorial teaching to your
own large group teaching which is the
kind of teaching that most of us will do
just for cost reasons so I wish you best
of luck in all your teaching it's
constant
yeah basically we teach too much stuff
and that's the fundamental problem and
so one solution to that is to say look
all the details get it from a book and
in class we're gonna do what you can't
easily do from the book which is
struggle argue reason and correct those
reasons that's hard to do from a book so
you should use the class time for
something that's value-added that you
can't do elsewhere so good luck with
that
please take a minute to fill out the
feedback sheets and and long as no one
kicks us out I'll be here as long as
people have questions answers from
lecture seven two questions generated in
lecture six
okay so questions from before what are
your suggestions for someone teaching a
course isn't that they are not expert in
at all you know is for the first time so
I'm a practical man I know most people
when they're teaching a course teaching
is not going to be their life I mean it
is for me but that's unusual and you
know you if you love teaching that's
great but probably your job will be
dependent on how much research you do or
other activities like department
committees and so you don't want to
destroy your whole career on your first
course by which I mean just try to
survive your first course because what
you could do the first time you're
teaching and so the the answer is you
need to somehow become an expert if you
want to teach it differently and
creatively interestingly you somehow
need to become an expert now you could
do that by spending the whole summer
before and really figuring out the
material from scratch and that probably
in the long term is a good thing you
probably find useful results in your
research from it but probably you don't
have that summer to do that and so what
you need to do is multi is kill two
birds with one stone and become an
expert by teaching it in which case the
best plan I would recommend is just to
teach it pretty much the regular way
with some interactive changes in lecture
but just follow the regular plan as much
as it sticks in one's craw because in
doing that first of all you won't be
rocking the boat so people will accept
it even if it's not great and you'll
become an expert by the end and then the
next time you teach it you'll be okay
then you you've done that summer of
thinking but you've done it during the
class okay so it meant the first class
didn't go as well as it could but it
also meant you survived and you could
order material for your lab and all the
other things that you do in the summer
okay
how do you so I like it when you
emphasize that it's okay to get the
wrong answer
it's like talking with like with the
wood blocks I mentioned how mostly when
I asked this of physics professors to
people get it mostly wrong and so I had
another example of that in Colorado
because I gave a talk using the wood
blocks so how can you incorporate that
it's okay to be wrong as long as you
learn attitude into class one of the
best ways is to minimize the amount of
grading and the emphasis given to
grading grading basically as a first
approximation so if I just add two
letters it's hard to avoid that so
grading when you mark someone and you
tell them bad ABCD well the people
you're giving B C's and DS whatever they
quote bad grades are that you are
actually shaming people and in some ways
you are degrading their psyche so it's
not healthy and so that is one of the
political barriers to educational change
is the importance that we give to
grading and I will talk about that in
the final session you may think oh well
what about the people who get A's well
if you're giving a B C's and DS the
people will get A's they may they may
have struggled and we're thinking oh my
god we're like getting a will I get an A
and then they get an A so they have Shue
but still they were nervous about their
learning the whole time instead of
enjoying it as much as they could and
second there's also studies many studies
which show that when you reward people
for things they already enjoy this is
totally fascinating so when you reward
people for things they already enjoy
doing their enjoyment drops so if you
start paying people for things that they
would like doing anyway then they don't
like it as much and you prey up everyday
examples of this would you know if you
know anyone who's a symphony orchestra
player they say oh yeah the best way to
start hating music is to be a
professional musician right they love
music and then they'd be kit for pay and
all of a sudden they don't like it
much anymore not all of a sudden but
slowly so there are many many studies
about that about motivation so what you
want to do really is to find intrinsic
motivation and so the difference between
extrinsic and intrinsic motivation is
fundamental and what you want to try to
do is create the environment always
where the motivation is intrinsic so
that the questions are interesting so
what that means is you don't want to use
bad questions that people don't have an
interest in and then force them to be
interested because you give them
extrinsic motivation that's a
fundamental bad choice and then it's
being solved with a fundamental wrong
approach what do you need to do is
rather than do both of those you say
okay let me find interesting questions
that people care about and then the
intrinsic motivation carries people
through whether they're right or wrong
so that's why I like questions like the
wood blocks so much because people are
just actually interested they want to
know they say oh that's a good question
I should know that oh maybe I don't okay
well maybe I'll learn something so the
other part of that is if you notice I
didn't use clickers when we did this
question partly it's because clickers
are expensive and you have to bunch of
logistics to do and then you need
probably some ludicrous Windows program
to receive the signals and I haven't
written a Linux version for it so
there's all of those issues those are I
would say not that the fundamental issue
the fundamental issue with clickers why
I don't like them is that they make
people think they're being spied on
so even especially if you live in a
surveillance society where actually all
your phone calls are being spied on
people might think low when you have
clickers you're being spied on to know
whether you got the right answer or not
and it's going to count against you at
some point so I just happy with people
to just raise their hands and that's you
know way more anonymous than a clicker
that belongs to you so there are ways of
getting around that with clickers you
can have people trade clickers so they
know that the clickers are random so you
can do things like that but still I like
the informal feel of yeah just raise
your hand don't worry it's a safe space
in the classroom and I have to say that
a few times but just raise your hand and
and don't worry and I'm not spying on
you I don't care whether you get the
right answer or not for example with the
wood blocks I expect most people to get
the wrong answer
and that's okay we'll learn something
about it afterwards okay so you do have
to work at it but there are things you
can do to keep the class safe there are
also things to do which is that never
it's hard to remember how much power you
have as the instructor right and just as
someone in a lot of position of
authority so I might have told you the
story from when I was a graduate student
but it's worth telling again if I
haven't which is that I was giving a
talk and group meeting when I was a
graduate student my adviser got
frustrated with me because I wasn't
understanding some fundamental point
actually about Springs so to demonstrate
it he kicked the table at me and said
it's just acting like a spring and I was
so shocked I was just mortified for like
two days I just couldn't believe my
adviser had done that in front of
everybody else and thought that you know
I must be an idiot and showed it and so
then eventually my fellow grad students
said well actually he does that only
when he really cares so that's better
than people just switching off so I've
sort of consoled myself with that but it
did make a real strong impression on me
how much even a small push from someone
an authority can do so it's the same
thing in lecture if when someone says
something wrong nah when some if you say
oh why would you have said that even the
slightest hint of that people magnify
and we'll pick up and be very very
sensitive to so you have to be really
really really careful not to let that
happen so one way is the poker face so I
practice the poker face so I when people
are making suggestions for example about
the wood block why they would act one
way or another I just make sure I get in
a different mental state the mental
state is transcription so I just want to
make sure I understand what people are
saying and then I just write that down
now it's even there you have to be
careful because you'll understand the
correct answer quicker than you will the
uncorrect answer so you have to make
sure when people are explaining the
correct answer you don't complete it for
them and then in contrast when people
are explaining a wrong answer you ask
lots of questions
because that too is a signal so you the
poker face is pretty is tricky to do but
once you master it that's one good way
of giving yourself a paw
and not criticizing people for their
answers now so there are various ways
but you just have to be careful and if
you do that regularly you'll find in a
week or two you've overcome the
presumption people have that it's
dangerous to ask questions what do you
do have to work in how is it possible is
it possible to incorporate mastery
learning at the college level so
actually there is a very interesting
experiment on that and it was done at
MIT in the 1970s I believe it was called
so it was called the Keller plan I don't
know if they did it for all courses but
the physics courses were taught this way
I don't know only that way or that was
an option so it was in the 1970s which
was a time of as peoples who are here
then said it was a very turbulent time
and the turbulence was actually enabled
lots of educational experiments to
happen basically the 60s and 70s so if
you look at for example the Fineman
lectures were in Caltech in the 60s the
Berkeley physics course 1960s things
like the Keller plan the free schools at
the school level
tons of experiments happen in the 60s
and 70s
so the Keller plan was one of them was
master e-learning students worked on
problems and when they were ready for
the next piece they continued and from
what I can tell it worked pretty well
but then eventually it got killed off by
basically faculty who said no I'd rather
teach and do lectures because the what's
the point of the faculty if the students
can learn really well from the books so
I think the Keller plan was a really
good idea I learned in school I learned
four or five years of high school math
in three or four weeks using the Keller
plan compared to the normal pace in
school where you spend a whole year
doing trigonometry so the Keller plan is
a really really excellent way if you
have reasonable books now
so now
what are the full reasons that died I'm
not really sure I need to check into
that but people who are around then some
of them said yeah it's just people who
wanted to perform in lecture were really
sad about the Keller plan and wanted to
go back to the old way and so when the
political currents changed so did the
Keller plan how do I come up with these
rich and interesting examples like the
wood blocks and how often do you
incorporate demos but we'll talk about
that in Walter Lewin's lecture so if you
saw Walter Lewin's lecture the one on
pendulum he must have had four or five
different demonstrations so they were
short but he had many demonstrations and
questions like this if I had 20 of these
I would use 20 20 different ones so
usually I have like four or five of them
that are a good long time demo that are
suitable for say half a lecture or
longer and I use those so wherever I can
find them I use them but not every
single demo is worth spending 30 or 40
minutes on so you have to think about
whether it teaches core ideas how it
fits with your goals of your course so
for example why let me talk through why
I use this one well one of the goals
that I want is I want students to be
able to make physical models themselves
and I want them to just be able to solve
equations that I put in front of them so
normally what you do is you teach them
the bending beam equation and then maybe
you'd show them this and then you do
this in two or three minutes but
actually the much more interesting
question is not what's the solution the
bending beam equation when the beam is
twice as thick the question is what
physical model is responsible for making
sound when you hear sound where is it
coming from when you tap this guy why is
it making sound long before you're even
discussing the bending beam equation so
that question is to my mind much more
interesting and so I'm very willing to
spend more time on that and having
students develop that feel and have them
argue and realize that there's different
physical models it could be a standing
wave in the block it could be that the
block is bending how do you decide and
how do you decide which one you're gonna
hear more and then for each one how do
you figure out how the frequency is
going to change
so that because it fits so well with the
course goals spend more time on it why
is the stiffness a factor of eight
bigger so that one anyone who wants to
know I will explain after lecture just
come to office hours yes so there's a a
a simple picture using wood atoms don't
ask what what atoms are okay how can you
incorporate aspects of mastery learning
into regular teaching ah so that's what
interactive teaching is all about so the
reason mastery learning works so well is
that you're not building castles of
knowledge on sand so roughly speaking so
normally what happens so the extreme
case is Cambridge in England so the
teaching system there is you have
eight-week term and then you have a six
week break and then an eight week term
six-week break eight-week term and then
sixteen week break so the eight week
term about what we would do in a
semester is compressed into eight weeks
just basically straight dictation in
lecture and the students have a hard
time really understanding everything at
that pace so they just take dictation
and then you're supposed to figure
everything else out integrated in the
six week break so the problem with that
is that it's very inefficient I it's
very inefficient because you haven't
understood a and now B uses a but be a
hasn't really been understood so you're
not gonna understand B so now you have a
and B not really understood so you just
write them down now C comes along using
a and B but a and B aren't understood so
you the problem compounds whereas with
mastery learning only when you
understand aid you go on to B and also
when a B are solid then you go on to C
so your knowledge castles are robust and
strong and that's not true with most
teachings so how do you remedy that
problem well one way is you ask
questions in lecture so here plan
interactivity and build it into your
lecture
so by asking students questions you
figure out oh if only 20% or 30% or
maybe even 40% of the students knew the
correct answer and even after discussion
you think okay well this is a
fundamental concept presumably that's
why you asked the question about it but
it wasn't mastered so better fix it
before you go on
so that builds mastery learning into the
regular lecturing process and that's one
reason that interactive teaching is so
effective so one of the other questions
later in the sheets is is there evidence
that interactive teaching is good and
helps people learn there is actually
good evidence maybe I should put some of
those papers online one is by Richard
Haight who's a he's now retired he's a
physics professor from Indiana
University so what he did is he he did a
sample of classes physics courses across
the country intro physics courses that
included the total of 6,000 students and
he asked the instructors to describe how
they did everything and then everything
was rated grouped into either
interactive teaching or regular teaching
and just the the scores that students
got on one particular exam which was a
force concept inventory before and after
they were given the force constant
memory before the class started and at
the end they saw how much the students
improved okay so if you improved a
hundred percent in other words suppose
you started at twenty percent correct
and you got to 100% that was considered
a 1.0 gain if you got went from 20% to
60% that meant you got halfway to the
maximum possible score you could have
gone so half of the maximum improvement
that was a gain of 0.5 so he measured
the game for everybody
this is Shakespeare so this is the gain
on the force concept inventory and this
is the number of courses in each area so
it was roughly like that so this was the
regular and so the regular teaching by
the way included fantastic teachers you
know people who were rated highest
lecturer in the university had one
lecturing awards and the interactive
teaching was something like this and
I'll I'll put the paper online so you
can see the exact graph but basically
the worst interactive teaching was
better than most of the regular teaching
and the regular teaching hardly got
better than 0.2 or 0.3 so if you wanted
any more game than that you really
needed to do interactive methods and I
think that is because you've
incorporated mastery learning into the
curriculum okay what do you do when the
students are really quiet won't answer
your questions thank you or flipside is
what if only the quote 5% usual suspects
are the ones answering the questions
what do you do well so that this is
which is related to the question of are
there bad ways of incorporating
interactivity and there are the worst is
the following which is I'll sort of
parody it
so we're doing relativity or nuclear
physics e equals MC squared yeah okay so
you'll find a lot of people who normally
wouldn't teach interactively or now they
there's Berthold or they've here that
it's good to teach you interactively and
ask students questions but if you don't
have any practice in how to do that the
easiest questions to ask you're just
things like this and the problem with
that is not that they're asking a
question it's good to ask you a question
but the problem is that this thing this
too is just to memorize fact so it's
possible to answer it just by memory
whereas if there was actually some
debate about it what it should be you
could ask the students the question but
now if you just ask people a question
like that
and you give people no time to think yes
you will get answers just from the quote
top 5% the usual suspects so in to avoid
that what do you need to do is give
people a chance to think on their own so
that's one of the interactive teaching
techniques the idea give people a minute
or even 30 seconds to think on their own
now so that your you'll get answered
from a wider spectrum of people because
they've checked it out with their
neighbor and they feel safer in
volunteering an answer or asking a
question about it okay so that's how you
avoid two things two problems at once
you avoid the quiet students because
you've given those students being quiet
because you're giving people a chance to
think and you've also avoid the problem
of just the usual people answering
because you've given everybody a chance
to think
okay if we if we don't really understand
until we teach should we have students
teach each other and presentations or is
that not worth the time ah my feeling is
that huge big presentations of having
students present to each other is not so
much worth the time I mean it's worth
the time of the one person who is doing
the presentation but that's the that's
the main person who learns in that
teaching session so there are several
graduate seminars many I took as a
graduate student that are run in the
following way the professor just sits
back and each time and they assign a
list of topics and each student
volunteers for one topic to present to
everybody else now that is a fantastic
way to learn one topic in the entire
course and it does work for that and
part of my PhD came out of one of the
topics that I learned from one of those
courses because I really wanted to
figure it out right so it can work and
it does work in some ways but it's not a
very efficient way because all the other
people are just basically passive yeah
they read the stuff but now they're
being taught by someone who's just
barely mastering the field and is not
likely to teach interactively with a
Mart large margin of safety so it's much
better to have students teach each other
by having them argue with each other on
small time scale so for example if you
remember in the wood blocks I said okay
argue with your neighbor about your
answer well now the students are trying
to teach each other some students think
oh yeah it's a due to the bending okay
well that it turns out to be correct but
can you convince your neighbor well in
trying to convince your neighbor you are
doing teaching now you're trying to
figure out what's a weight that you can
do it without writing down 50 equations
that's exactly what you want to do in
teaching so I think it's a much better
way is to build the interactivity into
the class for everybody rather than
having it as a rotating seminar where
just one person at a time learns okay
in organizing big ideas into a tree
they're off in multiple ways
for example you can do current
understanding versus history or
experiment versus theory and it's often
good for students to know more than one
of these organizations how do you do
that in the course design yeah I mean
though unfortunately there's only one
time dimension right there's three space
dimensions but only one time dimension
so the course has to evolve in one
dimension somehow so you need at least
one organization but you're right you
need other organizations as well so the
way I square that circle is these
follows so let's say time goes that way
so this is a unit one let's say it's one
technique one mode of reasoning
dimensional analysis let's say this is
another mode of reasoning conservation
and so on so these are units and now you
have topics well what I like to do is I
want to show other organizations and why
is that good well what you're doing is
you're connecting your drawing building
threads across your right you definitely
want to do that so what I'll do is I'll
find problems that can be solved
multiple ways suppose this is for
example problem about a pendulum well
you can solve a pendulum with
dimensional analysis you can also solve
a pendulum with conservation laws so
I'll do it again so this way this method
is sufficient to solve it mostly this
method is efficient but now we're
revisiting the old problem so I try to
find problems that thread through and
maybe then reappear over here so that
gives you another a cross-cutting
organization so you can do that not just
with problems but with for example other
principles for example the history
suppose you want to incorporate
experiments history versus current
understanding well every time you
mention history and the importance of
the history you say oh look there's a
yet another example of where we learned
from history learned it here
you've learned in this unit so now
the students have yet another structure
to bind the cords together okay so this
is hard to do the first time you teach
the course what you'll do is this first
time you teach your course well you
probably do it the regular way the
second time you maybe reorganize it this
way and the third way time you do it you
start building all the bridges across it
because that's the only time you
actually see them to kick how much what
are my thoughts on grade inflation I
wish every grade was an A so I think
there isn't enough of it because of
these studies I said before so I'll talk
about that in the penultimate lecture
okay
okay I think most of these yeah I think
I've now answered with other comments of
questions that are except for one which
I'll save for next time